[Music]
in the first shape of active reason
self-consciousness took itself to be
Puri individuality and it was confronted
by an empty universality in the second
the two sides of the antithesis each had
both moments within them law and
individuality but one side the heart was
their immediate unity the other of their
antithesis here in the relationship of
virtue and the way of the world the two
members are each severally the unity and
antithesis of these moments or each are
a movement of law and individuality
towards one another but a movement of
opposition for the virtuous
consciousness law is the essential
moment in individuality the one to be
nullified and therefore both in its own
consciousness as well as in the way of
the world in the former's case one's own
individuality is to be brought under the
discipline of the universal the
intrinsically true and good but under
that discipline it still remains a
personal consciousness true discipline
requires nothing less than the sacrifice
that the entire personality is proof
that individual peculiarities are in
fact no longer insisted on in this
individual sacrifice the individuality
in the way of the world is at the same
time eradicated for it too is a simple
moment common to both in the way of the
world individuality behaves in a way
which is the reverse of its behavior in
the virtuous consciousness that is it
makes itself the essential moment
whereas what is intrinsically good and
true it subordinates to itself further
the way of the world too is for virtue
not merely this universal which is
perverted by individuality on the
contrary the absolute order is likewise
a common moment only one that is not
present for consciousness as an existent
reality but as the inner essence of the
way of the world that order strictly
speaking has not first to be brought
into existence by virtue for to bring
into existence is quite action a
consciousness of individuality an
individuality is really what is to be
nullified but this nullifying of
individuality merely makes room as it
were for the in itself of the way of the
world to enter into existence on its own
account
here in paragraph 381 we're now entering
into the last section of this
actualization of self consciousness
portion of the massive reason section so
we've been sort of drilling down
drilling down drilling down and now
we're at the last of these three shapes
Gestalt and of consciousness that
individual consciousness in its
practical activity takes on we look
first at at pleasure the sort of
individual pleasure taking and it
encountered a necessity of we're going
to see talked about here and then we
have this whole dialectic that was
somewhat longer of the law of the heart
and the frenzy of self conceit and now
we're going to talk about virtue to end
and the way of the world of dealt love
and here we're going to have the themes
from the previous ones brought to a
higher level this is out of Haven right
as we see going on now I do want to
stress something as we move into this in
part because this term virtue tends to
get used in two different ways that are
not particularly helpful to have in mind
here it has a kind of old-fashioned e
sound to it which makes sense Hegel's
writing in the early 19th century after
all when people did talk quite a bit
more about virtue than they do today and
so I think too many readers they
associate it with kind of a formality
and a stiffness and almost you know
Victorian mores if we're talking about
English speakers and that's not quite
right that's not quite what he has in
mind although that's actually somewhat
close to it
other people when they hear virtue are
going to think you know of this recent
term virtue signaling I think most of
the people who use that term don't
really have any clear conception of what
virtue would would possibly mean or be
but generally what they mean by that is
something more or less along the lines
of what what David Hume means by virtue
which is you know any sort of socially
acceptable and you know lauded character
trait so anything that that that people
think is a good trait and that's not
quite the same as what what Hegel is
talking about here the other thing I
want to caution you against and and this
key talks about explicitly a little bit
further on in paragraph 390 is that
we're not talking about the kind of
virtue that we would associate with
virtue ethics virtue ethics in the
present understood as either being a
revival or a continuation of a
traditional way of understanding virtue
which comes down to us from the ancient
world with with thinkers like Plato or
Aristotle or the Stoics or or Cicero so
he doesn't have in mind either of these
two things and I think it's good for the
moment just to sort of suspend ones
conception and see what would he
actually does mean by virtue remember
that in this this section Hegel takes
what what's going on as being something
very typical of modernity modernity is
he understands it not necessarily the
modernity that we live and we're in late
modernity he is in the sort of
transition point from you know early
modernity to middle modernity the
Enlightenment is kind of you know run
its course and they're moving into the
the 19th century so what have I got here
on the board this is what he's talking
about in the very first part of this he
says in the first shape of active reason
what was that that was pleasure and
necessity self-consciousness took itself
to be pure individuality and it was
confronted by an empty universality so
that that's the dialectic that we went
through in that section just two
sections before right you start out by
seeking pleasure as an individual you
run into fate or necessity or whatever
it is you want to
it's an empty universality then we have
a transition Hegel narrates that in this
way in the second the two sides of the
antithesis each had both moments within
them so law and individuality or
universality and individuality now are
not quite so opposed to each show
they're not immediately as we see as we
see and we've got this locus of the
heart and in the heart as we see there
is a unity and einheit law and
individuality well at least for a little
while right because at the same time
there is also a opposition or an
antithesis of law and individuality as
well and we saw this entire dialectic
playing itself out it was very
interesting we don't need to go back
through that at this point so he says on
one side the heart was there mediate
unity on the other the antithesis now
here's the key transition he says here
in the relationship between virtue and
the way of the world the two members are
each severally on their own each of them
are the unity and the antithesis of
these moments or are each a movement of
law in individuality towards one another
but a movement of opposition so what
we've got going on here this was very
simple this was getting complicated this
is even more complicated than this was
we're reaching a higher level of
complication and I didn't bother to sort
of sketch all this stuff in there we've
got a unity and antithesis of law and
individuality both on the part of virtue
and on the part of the way of the world
the two of them are going to be
struggling with and against each other
in terms of the individual and the
individuals relationship with law or
with the universality or as we're going
to call it here virtue
so how does he parse this out he says
the verge for the virtuous consciousness
law is the essential moment so what does
it mean to be virtuous this is part of
why cautioned you against thinking in
terms of ancient virtue which tended to
be along what we can call you Dinah
mystic lines right Aristotle says well
you want to be virtuous so that you can
be you diamond that is happy the Stoics
you know also of a conception of
happiness which is largely you know
freedom and and and apatheia aquabox
eeeh as well that's not the way that
that that Hegel is understanding virtue
here it's being understood in what we
could call a more de ontological way
that is is for is focused on duty or
right or what one ought to do right so
this is this could be virtue in in the
sense that contests talking about in the
metaphysical elements of virtue but it
doesn't necessarily have to be a conch
and it could be all sorts of other
understandings so says for the virtuous
consciousness law is the essential
moment individuality the one to be
nullified and therefore both in its
consciousness as well as in the way of
the world so this is a transformation
Hegel is saying that look in this law of
the heart you know you're you're an
individual and you're you're trying to
find within yourself some sort of basis
for how things ought to be changed out
there and you you know you may regard
yourself as perverse or you know I'll go
through all these things but you're
still subjectivity that that is still
doing that and your individuality is you
might say the vehicle for that so he
says in the former case one's own
individuality is to be brought under the
discipline of the universal the
intrinsically true good but under that
discipline it still remains a personal
consciousness under the law of the heart
it's still your law of your heart right
or perhaps somebody else's love their
heart that you're reacting against
according to the law of
your heart we saw that that entire
dynamic leads to the way of the world
that's not going to be the case over
here with virtue here he says true
discipline true discipline not not
shamming discipline not halfway there
discipline true discipline requires
nothing less than the sacrifice of the
entire personality as proof that the
individual peculiarities are no longer
insisted upon now that's where it gets
very interesting right because we are
still going to have individuals acting
and and you can't there's a paradox here
you can't sacrifice your individuality
totally without still remaining an
individual because if you do then there
isn't really a sacrifice left right but
we're getting a lot closer to that so he
says in this individual sacrifice the
individuality in the way of the world is
at the same time eradicated for a to is
a simple moment common to both why well
it tells us in the way of the world
individuality behaves in a way which is
the reverse of its behavior in the
virtuous consciousness so the way of the
world and virtue are directly opposed to
each other what is the way of the world
well we're going to see in the
paragraphs right you know to come after
this that the way of the world means
following out your own individuality say
chasing pleasure or following the law of
your heart and saying screw you to the
society that doesn't get you and that
you want to try to change virtue says no
no no no that's enough of that nonsense
here's something that matters more and
if you want to do your own thing that's
the way of the world that's not what I'm
about you want to be in touch with the
universal the really good universal you
need to sacrifice so he goes on and he
says
here we go in the way of the world
individuality behaves in a way which is
the reverse of its behavior in the
virtuous consciousness what is that it
makes itself the essential moment
whereas what is intrinsically good and
true it subordinates to itself
individuality and this is something that
that might be hard for some you know
people to grasp in our society
individuality is not good in and of
itself there are higher things higher
values that matter more than just
getting your own way or imposing your
own you know views upon the rest of
society because you think that you're
you know more in touch with what's good
or what's true what's genuinely good or
true is is in some respects above us and
compels some respect and even sacrifice
from us so he goes on he says further
the way of the world is for virtue not
merely this Universal which is perverted
by individuality on the contrary the
absolute order is likewise a common
moment only one that is not present for
consciousness as an existent reality but
as the inner essence of the way of the
world all right we have this absolute
order that's embodied in the way of the
world so he says that orders strictly
speaking doesn't have to be brought into
existence by virtue virtue doesn't have
to accomplish that because bringing into
existence is here's an interesting point
is quite action a consciousness of
individuality and individuality is
really what is to be nullified so you
know you see this quite often people who
are trying to be virtuous but they're
really doing something more like
following the law of the heart they
haven't quite gotten what virtue is and
wants from them or demands from them and
when they find out oftentimes they turn
away from it when they realize the
sacrifice it's it's requiring suddenly a
virtue is not quite so attractive so he
goes on and he says this nullification
of individuality merely makes room as it
were for the in itself of the way of the
world
enter into existence on its own account
what what does he mean by that well it's
not as if the way of the world wasn't
there already the individuality can
become conscious of that
by contrast to virtue and by contrast to
the law of the heart but what the
individual is doing by by you know sort
of retreating or sacrificing him or
herself as individual is making room for
what is there to be seen and part of
this is going to be seen in other people
and in institutions and how things work
that's why it's the way of the world
right there's also going to be seeing
traces of it within oneself
and and that's going to be an important
theme as we move in into this section
the general content of the actual way of
the world we already know looked at more
closely it is again nothing else but the
two preceding movements of
self-consciousness from them has issued
the shape of virtues since they are its
origin they are antecedent to it but
virtue proceeds to nullify its origin
and to realize itself in other words to
become for itself the way of the world
is thus on the one hand the single
individuality which seeks its own
pleasure and enjoyment it is true that
in doing so it destroys itself in the
satisfies universal but there's very
satisfaction like the rest of the
moments of this relationship is a
perverted form and movement of the
universal the reality is only the
individuality of the pleasure and
enjoyment to which however the universal
is opposed a necessity which is merely
the empty form of the universal a merely
negative reaction and an action devoid
of content the other moment of the way
of the world is the individuality which
claims to be law in its own right and in
its own conceit disturbs the existing
order the universal law it is true
preserves itself in the face of this
conceit and no longer makes its
appearance as something opposed to
consciousness and empty of content as a
blind necessity but as a necessity
within consciousness itself but when it
exists as the conscious relation of an
absolutely contradictory reality it is
madness as an objective reality however
it is perversion in general the
universal that does display itself in
both aspects as the might which moves
them but the existence of this might is
merely a universal perversion
here in paragraph 382 Hegel is answering
for us the question well what exactly is
the way of the world what are we talking
about here
and we're gonna see it assume some
specificity at this point that is
connected to the two previous sections
it'll take on a bit more but he's also
setting out for us what we could call an
analysis of the the origin of virtue and
what its origin tells us about it virtue
goes against its own origin he says and
so this is going to be an important
point to stress because this is where
freedom is is showing itself in the way
that virtue which seems to be compelling
us against our freedom asserts itself
against the the way of the world adds
something for itself so what exactly is
the way of the world you says the
general content of the actual way of the
world we already know why do we already
know it well we went through these two
previous dialectics right look at more
closely he says it is again nothing else
but the two preceding movements of
self-consciousness pleasure and
necessity and the law of the heart and
the frenzy of self conceit these two
dialectics that represent shapes of
consciousness that we've now gone
through so he says from them has issued
the shape the form the shape of
consciousness virtue and we're going to
come back to that in a moment because
that that's very important how is virtue
emerged or issued or derived from from
this stuff it's by way of opposition but
we have to chart that out so he says
since they are its origin they are
antecedent to it but virtue proceeds to
nullify its origin and to realize itself
in other words to become for itself
Hegel doesn't tell us much more
out that at this point but we want to
come back to that at the very end of
this discussion think about what that
tells us about what he's calling virtue
here so he goes on and he says the way
of the world is thus on the one hand the
single individuality which seeks its own
pleasure and enjoyment its satisfaction
right we saw this in pleasure and
necessity the at least the early parts
of that section the the being says well
you know I don't have the ethical
substance of a functioning culture and
society that gives me my place and my
bearings how I'm gonna enjoy myself you
know I'm not gonna remember back to the
the quote from Faust I'm not gonna spend
time like seeking knowledge the hell
with that
there's so much stuff out here that I
could be enjoying other people's bodies
you know nice things to eat and drink
all sorts of great experiences that I
can have and they do that and then it
turns out that like Hegel is gonna point
out here they encounter necessity as a
universal right he says the single
individuality sought its own pleasure
and enjoyment and he says it's true that
in doing so it destroys itself and thus
satisfies the universal but there's very
satisfaction here's the point like the
rest of the moments of this relationship
is a perverted form and movement of the
universal what what's wrong with it well
it's abstract it's empty
remember fate is what we don't really
know so you know that's not satisfying
to the person seeking pleasure because
they're no longer getting the pleasure
it's also not satisfying to
consciousness that's trying to figure
out what the hell am I and what am i
doing here and you know these big
questions just to fight well there's
fate that's it no that's that's not a
satisfying resting point that's not a
universal that is going to work for us
so he goes on and he says the reality is
only the individuality of the pleasure
and enjoyment to which however the
universal is opposed a necessity which
is merely the empty form
Universal a merely negative reaction and
action devoid of content it's not I mean
it is a human action insofar as as fate
or necessity involves other human beings
or comes about because of a consequence
of our own actions like you know say the
person who gets gout from eating and
drinking too much or something along
those lines right person who burns out
their capacity for enjoying pleasure but
it's it's not you know it's not telling
us anything it's not revealing anything
to us it's not a rich experience it's
just a you know running into something
that tells us no so what happens and
when we look at the way of the world so
he's not the way the world the law of
the heart he says here we go the other
moment of the way of the world right the
law of the heart is the individuality
which claims to be law in its own right
so it remember takes the universal into
itself I've got the universal now all of
you shut up and listen to me because I'm
going to tell you the way the things
ought to be not the crappy way that they
they currently are and I'm roughly
paraphrasing here aren't I so he says it
claims to be law in its own right and in
its own conceit disturbs disrupts the
existing order we saw this played out
quite a bit not only does it disrupt the
existing order and it's it's yearning to
help humanity it tends to tick off the
rest of humanity who are like hey why
the law of your heart buddy why not the
law of my heart who are you to tell me
what I need for my own improvement or
satisfaction and we see this all the
time when people are trying to help
other people out on the basis of
sentimentality or empathy or whatever
you like right whatever code word it is
for I'm going to be the one to give the
law to you
Oh suffering humanity suffering humanity
sometimes says hey
I don't want your help I'd like some
other kind of help instead so says the
universal law it is true preserves
itself in the face of this conceit no
longer makes its appearance as something
opposed to consciousness and empty of
content as a blind necessity but as a
necessity within consciousness itself
and this is what we saw in the last
several paragraphs of the law of the
heart but what does this lead us to
remember back to what was going on in
that section of the law of the heart why
is that the frenzy of self conceit
because it discovers a contradict or
eNOS within itself that it cannot escape
from this is madness as Hegel says Vons
in insanity but it's not so crazy that
it's totally broken with reality it
can't get away from the damaged reality
and the fact that by trying to iron out
or fix the perversions of the existing
order it has introduced its own
perversions and taken some of that into
itself and project it and it's like oh I
just made things fundamentally worse
things are even more screwed up now or
at least they're screwed up in different
ways so he says when it exists as the
conscious relation is an absolutely
contradictory reality it is madness as
an objective reality however it is
perversion in general so the universe
always says does display itself in both
aspects as the might the power which
moves them but the existence of this
might is merely a universal perversion
now we come back as I said to even
though he's not ending the paragraph on
this so this origin of virtue right
virtue is coming out as an alternative
as an opposition to all of this mess
here and virtue turns against as he says
its own origin it liberates itself from
its own origin and thereby becomes for
itself
in a certain sense the way the world
can't really understand virtue I always
have to represent it as something else
like oh you're just trying to get your
own way or you're just trying to seek
out your own pleasure buddy it has to
turn it into something in a certain
sense either about power or about you
know having its own enjoyment but virtue
is something different so what Hegel's
doing here really is quite interesting
and now we have to see where this goes